good afternoon the Secretary General
will update you on this informal meeting
of foreign ministers and then we'll have
time for a few questions okay
good afternoon uh we have just finished
our informal foreign ministerial meeting
let me start by thanking foreign
setting
[Music]
and then also thank his majesty King
model for his Hospitality in the last 30
nights
this meeting was unto you to discuss the
issues are to prepare for our Summit in
the business in July
we had a good unconstructive discussions
on our ambitious
we will take decisions to further
strength of the parents and defense
agree a new defense investment page with
two percent of GDP on defense as the
minimum and deepen our Partnerships with
our partners in the indo-pacific region
our Focus today was on how we can bring
Ukraine closer to Nato where it belongs
NATO is already providing unprecedented
assistance I'm confident that Ukrainian
forces now have the capabilities they
need to liberate more occupied lamb
but we need to do more we are working on
a multi-year package of support with
robust funding
this will ensure Ukraine's returns and
defense for the longer term
help rebuild its security and defense
sector and transition Ukraine from
Soviet era Doctrine equipment and
training to full interoperability with
NATO
we also discussed upgrading the existing
NATO Ukraine commission to a new NATO
Ukraine Council
this would be a significant step to
establish a joint consultative Forum
with Ukraine sitting at the table as
equals to discuss key issues for our
security
we also addressed Ukraine's membership
aspirations
all allies agree that NATO's door
remains open that is only for allies and
Ukraine to make decisions on membership
Russia does not have a veto
and all allies agree that Ukraine will
become a member of NATO
and we all agree that the most important
thing now is to ensure that Ukraine
prevails as a sovereign and independent
state
we don't know when the war ends but we
must ensure that when it does we have
credible Arrangements in place to
guarantee Ukraine Security in the future
and to break Russia's cycle of
aggression
we had a good discussion on all these
issues and I'm confident that we will
come to consensus by The Summit in
Vilnius
I'm also working hard to ensure that
Sweden's accession to Nato is completed
as soon as possible
I spoke to president erdogan earlier
this week and I tend to travel to Turkey
in the near a future
and I welcome that Sweden's new
anti-terrorist terrorism laws have come
into force today
that shows that Sweden has delivered on
what they committed to do Under the
trilateral memorandum uh concluded last
year in Madrid
and demonstrates that Sweden's Swift
accession will contribute to Alliance
Security
and with that I'm ready to take your
questions
Wall Street Journal in the first row
yeah
Michael's with the Wall Street Journal
thank you very much for the question you
said you're confident that you will
reach consensus by The Summit but uh how
confident are you that you will reach a
consensus that won't disappoint
ukrainians nobody is fighting and dying
for interoperability or going from uh
Council to a commission
and second if I may there's been some
sort of nascent discussion of a possible
uh what's being called a peace Summit
before the NATO Summit are you
aware of any of that is there any
discussion of that thank you
the first and foremost the most
important thing for NATO and of course
for Ukraine is to ensure that they win
this War uh and and we are providing
unprecedented level of support and at
the meeting today and at the Village
Summit next month I'm absolutely certain
that the main focus will be on how to
sustain and step up the concrete
Military Support to Ukraine with
equipment with ammunition with with
spare parts with everything they need to
be able to liberate more land uh I say
that because
um uh we we need to be extremely focused
on that and also knowing that over the
last weeks analysts have stepped up uh
not only delivering heavy armor modern
battle tanks but also the United Kingdom
has delivered a long-range cruise
missiles which are making a difference
on the battlefield and also allies
having a have now announced that they
will start training of pilots
on to be able to fly F-16 and other NATO
standard aircraft so of course this is
the main focus this is the most urgent
task this is what you have to focus on
every day and and of course ukrainians
they they are calling for more and we
are mobilizing and mobilizing more
support because it will be a tragedy for
you for Ukraine but it will also be
dangerous for us if President Putin wins
in Ukraine uh it it will make the world
more dangerous it will send a message
that when authoritarian leaders use
military force they get what they want
and that also make us more vulnerable so
I say that because I understand of
course that some of these more long-term
issues related to reforms
interoperability transition from Soviet
standard to Nato standard uh is is not
perhaps the most urgent task but it
matters it matters for two reasons it
matters point because it indicates a
long-term commitment sending a message
to Moscow that Preston Putin cannot wait
us out
uh I I believe that that in Moscow they
they they think that democracies are
lazy that we are ready to uh not not
understand by Ukraine for as long as it
takes and we are going to prove the
opposite by demonstrating that
democracies are actually able to stand
up for their values and be there when
they are needed to defend democracy and
freedom as we do when we support Ukraine
so these more long-term efforts the
multi-air
program of uh implementing the
transition from Soviet area to Nato
standards
it it sends a message of long-term
commitment which is important
second the interoperability
also matters for a more shorter term
because it is a challenge it is a
logistical challenge that there are so
many systems so many different types of
weapons so many different doctrines at
the same time on the Ukrainian side
so this is now a war or attrition award
attrition is a battle of logistics and
to to to help us win that battle of
logistics everything we can do to make
the Ukrainian forces more interoperable
and at the end fully interoperable with
NATO forces it also actually have a more
short-term effect on their ability to
win on the battlefield so uh so for me
there is absolutely no contradiction
between being focused on the urgent need
for military support and the more
long-term uh commitment also because the
long-term commitment sends a message to
Moscow that the President Putin can not
wait us out
foreign
well as we welcome uh efforts to find a
a peaceful solution but of course
we support the the Ukrainian initiatives
the the plans put forward by by
President uh solensky and I will leave
it to to president zlinsky and to the
ukrainians decide the formers and the
conditions for any peace talks and uh
and uh and political dialogue
uh Mr nyberg from the Norwegian
Broadcasting Corporation at the
beginning of this war when NATO
countries started to deliver
weapons to the Ukraine authorities
it was important that the weapons were
not long range and that they were they
were handed on the condition that they
were not targeting uh Russia on Russian
territory now asked uh
on what's your reaction to possible
Ukraine uh attacks on Russian soil your
answer is the ukrainians has the right
to defend itself
there is a change of tone and what has
changed
[Music]
uh and lighter weapon systems then
gradually we moved into delivering Heavy
Artillery then uh not only light and and
and and a man held uh uh and also in air
defense systems but also more heavier
and advanced Edison systems like the
nasim's and the and the Patriots and
then uh after uh some more months we
went into delivering also different
types of armor including the uh the the
the mortars and the and the and the and
the and the different uh uh different
types of uh Army personnel carriers uh
that have proven to be extremely
important and now also heavy armor and
battle tanks so yes you are right that
the type of support has evolved but that
reflects that the war has evolved and
that and that we have realized that
actually by delivering more advanced
weapon systems and the ukrainians are
able to defend themselves against all
these different air attacks but all so
to actually use the heavy armor uh the
artillery the high Mars to also liberate
more land but but fundamentally the
message is the same that NATO NATO
allies are important to the conflict we
and help Ukraine to defend itself that's
right and showing the new and shortly
and we'll continue to support Ukraine or
polling that right Reuters
thank you Sabina zebolt with Reuters
Secretary General could you tell us
whether ministers have agreed to hand
Ukraine in Williams any kind of a road
map for NATO accession and you were
talking about the framework of security
guarantees
um could you work out a little bit on
that one uh who should issue these
security guarantees and when should they
take effect thank you
thank you so first of all this was an
informal meeting we didn't make any uh
decisions uh what we discussed and it's
always useful to have all the allies and
also Sweden around the same table
systems and the ukrainians are able to
defend themselves against all these
different air attacks actually use the
heavy armor the artillery the harmars to
also liberate more land but but
fundamentally the message is the same
that NATO NATO always on a party to the
conflict we help Ukraine to defend
itself that's right and showing the new
and shortly and we'll continue to
support Ukraine Apollo in that right
Reuters
uh
thank you Sabina zebolt with Reuters
Secretary General could you tell us the
ministers have agreed to hand Ukraine in
Williams any kind of a road map for NATO
accession and you were talking about the
framework of security guarantees
um could you work out a little bit on
that one uh who should issue these
security guarantees and when should they
take effect thank you so first of all
this was an informal meeting we didn't
make any uh decisions uh what we
discussed and it's always useful to have
all the allies and also Sweden Iran uh
the same table actually there's no table
is sitting there in the ring but but I
have an informal discussion where The
Minister's not reading from manuscripts
actually happen on an open exchange
helps us to improve the understanding of
where we can find consensus how we can
move forward and again first of all they
all agree that NATO store is open that
Ukraine will come a member uh and it's
for NATO allies Russia to decide when
that will happen and they're also then
all messages will need to focus on the
Urgent task to ensure that we provide
the necessary support Military Support
to Ukraine so Ukraine prevails then I
think what we all realize but we still
have work to do we still have
consultations before we can make
decisions is that
Wars are unpredictable no one can say
how and when this war ends but what we
do know is that when it ends we need to
ensure that we have the Frameworks uh in
place to ensure that this is not a pause
in a pattern of Russian aggressive
attractions against the Ukraine because
the war didn't start in February last
year it actually started in 2014 with
the first communion and later on that
they went into donbos and we need to to
to to to to stop this vicious circle of
aggression against Ukraine
um uh because we need to be sure that
what happens after it's some kind of end
that Russia
reconstitute rest and then regroup and
then attack again uh in some months or
some years and to ensure that you
actually stop it there we need to
provide long-term Military Support
Ukraine multi-air programs as we have
discussed but also look into what kind
of Frameworks that we can establish to
to provide the necessary guarantees
that President Putin is not able once
again to attack Ukraine the details how
this will be done what kind of
mechanisms that remains to be decided
but the idea of preventing uh history
from repeating itself preventing
President Putin from continue to be able
to chip away at European security that's
the aim and then we discuss the means
just to to achieve that
radio
Mr Secretary General according to your
trip to Ankara more concrete which day
will you go does the president erda
knows that you will come and we'll try
to go there together with the Swedish
prime minister prime minister of Finland
thank you
well I I'm invited by the president so
so our staffs are now looking into the
the practicalities on the exact dates I
spoke with him two days ago president
adiron uh and uh and one of the things
we then agree that I should go once
again to Ankara I I I I I went there
also this fall uh to actually Istanbul
to spend some days there
um to to to discuss how to make progress
and uh and also different phone calls
and meetings has enabled us to to make
progress uh partly first of all actually
to may have the decision in in in June
last year to invite uh Finland and
Sweden which was a big decision
um uh that we all made together also a
president
last summer since then I have been close
and constant contact with
uh the the political leadership in
Ankara my staff we have this permanent
mechanism that meets also a regularly
and uh and then and then we agreed on
the way forward and also to ensure
um the ratification of Finland and now
there has been a period of elections in
Turkey so then the contacts are not
being so close and so intensive but
since now the elections are over I think
it's important to then restart the uh
the the dialogue and the process the
plan is for me to go alone but I'm
actually certain that will be all the
formats also to engage
with the Swedish political leadership
and of course we also stay in very close
contact with Stockholm I spoke with the
Swedish foreign minister uh here at the
NATO ministerial and of course we'll
stay in close contact with Stockholm
news agency
uh thank you Vietnam news agency I'm
Secretary General yesterday you strongly
condemned the dpprk satellite lunch but
today the dprk said rejected those
criticism insisting if I quote it's the
right to self-defense of them and do you
have any further comments on this and if
I may ask another one at the value
Summit what can we expect to be
discussed in terms of stepping a
cooperation with the indo-pacific
partners thank you
so I strongly condemn the military
satellite launched by North Korea using
a ballistic missile technology so
several U.N security Council resolutions
it's a threat to neighbors and uh and a
challenge to a global stability and of
course this launch raises tensions and a
poses serious risks to the security of
the region and the on and it's a very
clear breach of different U.N
resolutions
NATO calls on North Korea to seize these
provocative actions and to return to
dialogue in order to achieve sustainable
peace and the complete and the
verifiable denuclearization of the
Korean Peninsula we stand together with
our close Partners in the region and the
Republic of Korea and Japan and as we
may know I visited Japan and and the
Republic of Korea um not so long time
ago and the message there was that
security is not Regional security is
global what happens in Asia matters for
Europe and what happens in Europe
matters for for and therefore it is even
more important that NATO allies are
strengthening uh our partnership with
our indo-pacific partners uh for the
second time in history we'll have all
the leaders of the four Asia Pacific
Partners Australia New Zealand Japan
South Korea attending our Summit in in
Vilnius and uh and uh and also seen that
there has been a
request to have a little office and
we're looking into the possibility of
establishing the earlier Zone office
what signals did you get from uh did the
turkey season about the Swedish
membership application in this meeting
and the same goes for Hungary
so I will be careful in my uh speaking
on behalf of uh allies but in general I
can say that turkey has expressed that
they are supportive of Swedish
membership
um and turkey stand by the decision they
made to get with other allies to invite
Sweden of course and when you invite
Sweden to become a member the purpose is
to make a Sweden fall a member
then in the run-up to that decision last
summer
turkey raised some legitimate security
concerns related to the fact that no
other Allah has suffered more terrorist
attacks than than turkey and then we
address them and looked into how can we
further strength and what NATO do but
thus but also what NATO allies do to
work together with turkey and to fight
terrorism including organizations which
are recognized advice organizations also
by by Sweden by the European Union for
instance the pkk and then we agree this
trilateral memorandum that outline
Advanced need for a more exchange of
intelligence information working more
closely together but also where a sweet
Medicare that they're going to enhance
their
legislation on terrorism and all of this
is now implemented Sweden as of today
has put enforced new legislation
strengthening the tools they have to
fight by terrorism and we have
established a mechanism we're actually
now exchanged more information on
intelligence so my message is that
Sweden has delivered therefore the time
is has come to to ratify Sweden and I'm
working hard to ensure that that happens
as soon as possible when it comes to to
Hungary we have no indication that that
they have changed their position that
they will not be the loss to relatively
so in turkey or a device I'm actually
certain that also I'm confident that
those are hungry will do that because
they have said it before
that's all we have time for thank you
thank you so much